what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with nobody but i have pelina
on the line
it's a remote recording namaste in the
background
what's up don't forget them is now the
spawn
of lunch money once money it does not
get ads interrupted by polina
go ahead what were you gonna say we'll
wait i forgot okay
block five is now the sponsor of lunch
money you can buy and sell crypto on
their crypto exchange you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar loan
against your crypto collateral
or you can use my favorite product i'm
an investor i sit on the board and i
use the product which is their interest
bearing account where you can earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in that interest bearing account go get
an account today block five dot com
slash pomp do it be cool like
me wifi.com pomp all right what's
up all right u.s stocks fell sharply on
wednesday following their european
counterparts as investors worried that
the latest increase in corona virus
infections could halt
the global eco economic recovery the dow
jones industrial average dropped 823
points or three percent
the s p 500 2.9 and the nasdaq
composite traded three percent lower
who cares about day-to-day stock
movements one percent here two percent
here three percent here
who cares everyone's always speculating
on some nonsense
i get it there's people who are trying
to day trade and do all this stuff
the best investors in the world buy
assets hold them for long periods of
time day-to-day price fluctuations
don't matter but it's very funny to me
to see that everyone thinks that all of
a sudden as
cases are going up that we're going to
have this global shutdown
because hospitalizations are not going
up nearly as much from what i've seen
so could it be more testing maybe could
it be something else
maybe could it be the fact that we're
starting to reopen places maybe
i think that there's a lot of data
flying around and there's not
a lot of confidence in what is happening
and therefore as i've been saying since
march
it's really really hard to make good
decisions with bad
data what do you think miss paulina
yeah i mean i think that investors are
emotional and this is what happens when
things happen in the world
there's an election coming up huh
emotional investors
emotional control your emotions
facts okay them all had to do this all
right what's next
you know how yesterday we're talking
about contactless payments well
so today uh visa europe
ceo charlotte hogg said that the kobe 19
pandemic has sped up the shift
to contactless payments in e-commerce um
she said the coron virus hasn't killed
cash
but there has been a real shift to
digital you can see real
evidence of changes in behavior
just more proof that this is the future
yeah ain't nobody want to be touching
nothing
no right and if you can just walk in and
and do it real quick of course and also
i think that it's gonna be more secure
it's gonna be more efficient it's gonna
cost less like there's all this kind of
stuff that'll happen
um sorry it's interesting that a lot of
these companies have been trying to go
digital and contactless for so long but
they haven't been able to change
uh like user behavior but now with govid
like people are forced to do it so it's
kind of weirdly in favor of that for
those companies
covet is just accelerating all the
trends right you know we've talked about
this for months now but definitely
all right next okay so
okay so goldman sachs wants to help any
company in the world become a bank
the firm has just released software that
allows clients to embed
banking services onto their own products
as part of a push to break into the 32
billion a year
industry managing cash for big
corporations
what it's pretty smart wait
i i didn't read about i read this one uh
surprisingly i didn't see it on the
internet
but uh if you are goldman you have
basically two things
you can be uh a gold miner so you can go
look for the gold or you can sell the
picks and the shovels
and obviously being the platform or
selling the picks and the shovels to
everybody else and let them go use the
product
uh and you just take a small piece of it
that's a very profitable scalable
model so this is super smart if they can
get people to adopt it can they get
developers to use it can they get people
who are building you know various web or
mobile products
uh sure i could easily see this being
adopted
because also there's like the
financialization of everything right
you're getting more and more people who
are saying hey
i want to participate in some way uh in
kind of banking services and so now
here's somebody selling picks and
shovels and should be pretty profitable
so two things on this i used to think a
long time ago that
picks and shovels were pigs and shawls
and i was like i get the shovel part but
where does the pig come in
yeah um and two uh i think it's
interesting that goldman is kind of
acting like a tech company right it's
allowing
other people to build on top of its
software
they're all realizing that the tech
model is way better
yeah even media companies are realizing
okay that's for another time
all right so telling me not to say what
i want to say go ahead
wait what go ahead no you can say
whatever you want to say
media companies are competing with tech
companies and tech companies should look
at them as competitors and not as simply
people who tell their story anymore
and i think that tech companies should
look at the media companies and try to
take them down
if you're going to compete you can't
complain then when you get beat
that rhymed a little bit there's a whole
issue with freedom of speech and stuff
that you're promoting kind of
something else and dangerous but okay no
no no hold on just so we're clear
my whole point is no one's endangering
your freedom of speech
but if all of a sudden tomorrow facebook
and twitter
said hey the new york times now claims
that they're a tech company they're a
competitor
just like apple won't allow certain
services
to use their uh platform or just like
facebook won't give their social craft
to uh social media competitors
all facebook would have to say is you
know what we're not going to allow you
to share
new york times articles anymore on our
platform it's a competitor
can i ask you something of course where
do you get your news
i get it all over the internet okay but
you read articles right
of course because here's the problem
with people who are like oh just let
them
talk and you know um you can like on
twitter like you can share your own view
and somebody else can share their own
view and that's freedom of speech
yes but a lot of times
regular people they they don't
understand that
this person comes with biases they have
to read more to understand like are they
lying is this the truth is this whatever
media plays a really important role in
that i'm not disagreeing
on on the media side i think that the
new york times you should
hire more journalists and they should do
more journalism like keep
doubling and tripling down on what
they're good at but the second that you
say you're a tech company and you wanna
are gonna now go compete why should
facebook
and twitter give you free distribution
why is the new york times not paying for
that distribution
they're competing with them they're
using the services that facebook built
for it
so if all of a sudden facebook said hey
we're big fans of free speech
go do your free speech wherever you want
but build your own distribution platform
stop using ours
there's no right that any media company
has to the platforms
and that's what's happening that's why
there is such an anti-tech
bias is because what you're seeing is
the mainstream media companies are now
stepping in and they're all claiming i
mean you can just google
new york times tech company washington
post tech company they're all claiming
to be tech companies now
so okay well why would anybody say to
their competitor
hey i'm gonna help you be successful
that doesn't make a lot of sense
i know but facebook kind of thrives off
of
news organizations posting their
articles on there because otherwise what
news would people share it would only be
photos and statuses
again there would be a a pro and con or
risk reward
analysis that would have to be done what
is the impact if we don't allow them to
do this
and is that good or bad for our business
but my point is that there's just this
assumption
that mainstream media companies across
both
both sides and the independent so this
is not a republican thing a democratic
thing or an independent thing just
all extreme corporate type media
companies
there's an assumption that they have a
god-given right to distribution on
social media platforms
yeah i agree okay speaking of tech
companies
the ceos of facebook google and twitter
return virtually to congress today
to defend their legal liability shield
to lawmakers keen to weaken it
as we speak the hearing is going on the
executive
the executives face lawmakers on the
senate commerce committee
members unanimously supported the
hearing after its scope was expanded to
include discussions of digital privacy
and text impact on local media
so now i'm going to argue the counter
argument to what i just argued
which is if facebook twitter etc decided
that they were going to
start selectively preventing certain
types of
uh outlets from gaining distribution to
their platform
there would be incredible regulatory
pressure and lots of questions around
antitrust
anti-competitive behavior because again
my point in all of this
is that there is a competition the new
york times washington post
and whoever else wall street journal et
cetera they are competing with facebook
they are competing with twitter right
and so when you look at it from that
perspective
you have to start to wonder where is the
line
and i think that that's the reason why
the social media companies haven't done
something like this
is because the regulatory pressure would
be incredible
on anti-trust and anti-competitive
behavior what i find
interesting in these hearings is that
there's republicans and democrats
and somehow each side sees themselves as
the victims
of these big tech companies so for
instance republicans have complained
that the legal shield allows tech
companies to get away with removing
messages they disagree with
particularly those from conservatives
democrats on the other hand fear that
tech platforms have not done enough
to police their platforms and that
section 230 allows them to get away with
not taking appropriate
action so it's kind of like they're in
like this like weird middle
i think the hardest part about all of
this and it goes back to the competition
you know debate um and i'm presenting
two very polarizing
different perspectives on purpose
because i don't think that there's a
single answer
right like i see both sides of the
argument and i think that being able to
uh describe both arguments is important
because really
you start to get into the details of are
tech companies editorializing
the content you see right so like if i
make a phone call too we've talked about
this before if i make a phone call to
polina
and the uh phone company said nope you
know what you're talking
about uh doughnuts we don't like
doughnuts so we're gonna
yeah or zoom or like or whatever if they
said oh we don't like what's going on in
that conversation we're gonna shut off
the call
now you're starting to editorialize
you're you're providing some level of
censorship depending
on the content but the phone company
says we don't care what you talk about
we're never going to shut it down
all we are are communication pipes and
we don't actually make decisions based
on the content
what we're starting to see on the social
media platforms is that's what they used
to say
but when they have a ranked algorithm
now they are making decisions they're
promoting some things they're doing
some things now they're even going as
far as saying they're going to fact
check information right it's a big
divergence from just
hey we're the phone company to now
there's more editorial stuff
and so i think that what you're starting
to see is all these lines are blurring
and that's why i say they're all
becoming a competition
right so like i would argue in some
cases that
uh many major media companies they've
built social networks
they may not have a single platform but
what is the comments section
what is um all of the memberships that
they well
it was a lot of yeah and it was a lot of
um things kind of
coming at once because in the same
period of time where a
ton of media organizations said oh the
comments section is really bad and toxic
we're just going to shut it down
people didn't stop having conversations
and commenting they just moved to other
mediums
and that also uh came at the same time
with the rise of social media so those
conversations that were normally taking
place underneath the articles
are now taking place on facebook yeah i
think the big thing and before everyone
freaks out
the big thing here is you're probably
not going to find two bigger
proponents of free speech than planet
and i in terms of
one we should encourage as much free
speech even the people you disagree with
especially the people you disagree with
absolutely
two the mainstream media is actually
important
they provide a check on on power and all
these things
there is a very important role for
journalism in our society
three is that there is a confusion
about what is a right and what is a
nice thing to have so distribution for
example on a social media platform
is not a guaranteed thing whereas i
think that there's many people who
believe that it is
that's the third thing the fourth thing
is where we are headed
is a world where we don't want to go
we do not want the social media
companies editorializing things
deciding what gets promoted what doesn't
like this world that we're headed to is
a very very dangerous slippery
slope place and i think it's an
important conversation to have
right now before you head down that way
because ultimately we're going
i can't stop it planet can't stop it
nobody can stop it we're going there
but i do think that it's important for
people as they're consuming content to
remember
the content i'm seeing may not be the
full story i should take the personal
responsibility to educate myself
and i should go look at what is the
other side of this argument
so if somebody's telling me that you
know kovid's not bad it doesn't kill
people i should go figure out what's the
other side saying about why is it
killing so many people
right yeah well you know and it's not
always like one side versus the other
side it's like
look at look at all the facts and try to
make an independent decision
what scares me is that the path we're
going down is
a lot of people find speech that is
uncomfortable to them
it's not necessarily inciting violence
or anything like that
it's just uncomfortable to hear and they
are trying to suppress that speech and
that is
very dangerous i read um i read this um
horrific
uh survey that they did um where
they surveyed college students and there
was a significant percentage of college
students that
said that they would um they would
support
a certain level of violence to suppress
certain types of speech
and that's that's really terrifying
okay hard disagree okay next
um okay so you know the whoop band the
fitness tracking company
yes it monitors it monitors vital
movement sleep workouts all sorts of
stuff it's very popular
right now it just closed a hundred
million dollar
in funding which make which values that
at 1.2
billion dollars shout out to joe
bonpiano who wrote about it this morning
uh his newsletters huddle up huddle
up.com
and the funding the the round of
investors include
a bunch of athletes patrick mahomes rory
mcilroy justin thomas kevin durant
larry fitzgerald
is huh no he's a golfer
a golfer yeah you know he's a wide
receiver
yeah that's golf that's not i know that
plays in the nfl it's cool
it basically measures all your vitals it
tells you if you need to sleep if you
need to recover
what you're doing why it's working or
not working
uh how's it different from the apple
watch it's basically all the health
functions of the apple watch on steroids
so it like goes deeper and like it's a
specifically built thing
just for that uh you can't make phone
calls on it or do anything crazy
do we know why this trend is
accelerating of people wanting more and
more data
about their vitals
uh yeah i mean it's the quantified self
right everyone wants the data because
they want to change their behavior so
they want to sleep more they want to eat
better they want to you know get more
exercise they like all these different
things and now the data is available to
people in a consumer-friendly way
they're interested in getting it so the
quantified self is just a
trend that is increasing right yeah okay
final topic two years worth of
e-commerce growth is about to be packed
into one
holiday season as americans turn in
droves to online shopping to avoid
crowded stores and walls
during the corona virus pandemic so this
is really interesting because
every year you know there's black friday
there's like the last minute mall
you know christmas present shoppers
they're gonna be forced to do it online
this year
well you have lots of practice online
shopping
oh there's two packages for you
downstairs okay go on
why don't you describe what you think is
gonna happen in the e-commerce world i
personally don't have that much
experience with e-commerce but you
on the other hand are an expert well
i've been in e-commerce long before
you know this happened covet happened
but i i just don't like
because of kobit all these things where
you are packed
in a store like black friday will be
cancelled
so i think this is good for some of
these companies that have been trying to
go online these retailers
brick and mortar costs a lot of money et
cetera et cetera so let's
let's try this new thing it says it says
um
people are expected that um so adobe
adobe expects consumers could spend an
extra 11 billion dollars
online pushing total holiday spending
past 200 billion
it's wild that's 33
growth year over year crazy what joke
you got for me
okay so i don't have a joke but i have a
funny story okay
okay i did not tell you that i was gonna
do this but i'm gonna do it
so guys wait did i already tell them
this story
about the mexican restaurant no but you
have two minutes so hurry up
we went to a mexican restaurant and we
were having dinner um
and i ordered a chimichanga i really
feel like i already told the story i
ordered a chimichanga and had half of it
left
and then anthony goes um
just leave the rest for jimmy and i was
like who the hell is jimmy
and then you said jimmy changa duh
it's like louis baton louie from jersey
city and jimmy from
mexico city they hang out together i
thought jimmy chong was like some
billionaire
somewhere because he came up with jimmy
chong
ladies and gentlemen jimmy changer in
louboutin is when he was trying to say
louis baton and louis baton from jersey
city with the shoes
who meet chango from mexico city with
the chimichangas
okay i'm not that jimmy changa is not a
guy and that is not a thing
but that's fine we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends